bonsoir
bonsoir alors l'Arabie Saoudite est
investi des milliards de dollars en ce
moment dans la diversification de son
économie dans le tourisme dans les
vedettes sportives mondiales on a vu
Lionel Messi récemment Cristiano Ronaldo
des centaines de millions de dollars à
ses vedettes là qu'est-ce que l'Arabie
Saoudite est en train de faire
l'Arabie Saoudite est en train de
changer et de changer beaucoup si on
prend quelques années de recul autour de
2017 18 19 la politique étrangère y
était très agressive la guerre au Yémen
l'embargo sur le Qatar rappelle la
dispute avec le Canada mais dans les
années qui ont suivi autour de 19 20 21
il y a eu une prise de conscience
d'abord avant tout par Mohamed Ben
Salman le prince héritier de facto le
dirigeant du pays que cette politique
étrangère là agressive était très
coûteuse alors depuis un an ou deux on
voit des efforts importants de la part
du pays pour stabiliser ses relations
étrangères régler le plus de conflits
possibles réconciliation avec le Canada
la semaine dernière avec le Qatar dans
les derniers mois et tout ça comme vous
l'avez dit en introduction dans le but
de se positionner comme destination
beaucoup plus attrayante pour
l'investissement étranger le commerce
international mais aussi le tourisme et
c'est très impressionnant je vous
parlais de sportif mais il y a également
des investissements
ce projet de mégalopole
utopique sur la mer Rouge les images
sont incroyables c'est quoi l'objectif
ici
alors ce projet-là ça s'appelle NEOM qui
veut dire Neo Moustakbal en arabe ton
nouveau futur c'est une ville futuriste
on parle de centaines de milliards
d'investissements planifiés dans le
nord-ouest du pays donc près de là où
l'Arabie Saoudite rejoint ou est proche
d'Israël de la Jordanie et de l'Egypte
l'idée c'est que ce soit une ville
futuriste très verte au niveau
environnemental que ce soit un pôle de
recherche en technologie en intelligence
artificielle c'est un projet pharaonique
comme vous l'avez dit les travaux ont
commencé c'est sûr qu'il y a lieu d'être
sceptique que l'ensemble du projet va
être réalisé mais au minimum il y en a
une partie qui va l'être en tout cas
c'est l'argent du pétrole qui va être
là-dedans certainement les milliards et
les milliards
d'enrichissements du pétrole l'Arabie
Saoudite avec les États-Unis la Russie
font partie des principaux producteurs
du monde mais là l'Arabie saoudite a
annoncé une réduction de production en
fin de semaine pour stimuler les prix
le pétrole est au cœur de l'économie
mais est-ce que ça va durer comme ça
encore longtemps est-ce que le prince
Mohamed veut
diversifier davantage l'économie
absolument il y a eu une prise de
conscience importante en Arabie Saoudite
que l'absence de diversification de
l'économie ça dépendance au pétrole est
une vulnérabilité une vulnérabilité a
beaucoup plus long terme quand
éventuellement dans des décennies le
pétrole vont être moins importants mais
même à plus court terme une
vulnérabilité à la fluctuation des prix
alors dans le cas des réformes majeures
sociales et économiques dont j'ai parlé
tantôt il y a une volonté importante de
diversifier l'économie d'attirer le
tourisme il y a des investissements
majeurs dans ce secteur là mais aussi il
y a eu énormément d'argent qui ont été
pompé dans un fond d'investissement qui
lui va investir à droite et à gauche
dans le pays dans toutes sortes de
projets pour attirer des investisseurs
étrangers dans les domaines
technologiques manufacturiers etc est-ce
que cette transformation s'accompagne
quand même d'une plus grande ouverture
avec une moins grande répression
répression de la population
particulièrement on a quand même parlé
de beaucoup d'enjeux au cours des
dernières années est-ce que ça
s'améliore de ce côté là non et ça on
fait bien de poser la question les
réformes sociales et économiques en
Arabie Saoudite sont réels elles sont
majeures puis elles sont à plusieurs
égards révolutionnaires il y a beaucoup
de scepticisme en Occident des fois où
on pense que c'est juste des réformes de
façades et c'est pas vrai ceci étant dit
ces réformes là ne sont pas accompagnées
de réforme politique de réforme
démocratique non seulement il y en a pas
il y en aura pas à court ou à moyen
terme mais à plusieurs égards la
répression c'est même intensifié Mohamed
Ben Salman a bien compris que si relâche
la pression au niveau social et
économique en permettant par exemple
l'ouverture de cinéma il veut absolument
pas que ce soit accompagné par un
mouvement qui pourrait revendiquer
d'autres droits d'autres libéralisations
au niveau politique alors même souvent
de façon préentive il y a emprisonné
torturé beaucoup de militants par
exemple de la société civile pourquoi le
secrétaire d'État américain une tenue
Linkin est à jeda pour rencontrer le
prince Itier puis je vous pose aussi la
question pour le Canada qui vient de
rétablir aussi ces liens avec l'Arabie
Saoudite
il y a beaucoup de raisons pour
lesquelles on peut être en désaccord
avec beaucoup de choses qu'elle fait au
niveau des droits de la personne au
niveau de sa de la gare au Yémen elle
essaye de s'en extraire mais ça
fonctionne pas jusqu'ici mais ça empêche
pas que c'est un partenaire très
important pour les États-Unis pour le
Canada aussi même si on compte beaucoup
moins dedans sur cette échiquier là les
États-Unis l'Arabie saoudite ont eu
beaucoup de désaccords dans les
dernières années la guerre où il y a
même en est un mais plusieurs autres les
prix du pétrole comme vous l'avez
mentionné mais ces deux pays qui
demandent des partenaires très proches
ils vont encore travailler de très près
sur plusieurs enjeux diplomatiques
sécuritaire et autres on en parle moins
mais comme le contre terrorisme encore
donc la visite du secrétaire d'État
Linkin cette semaine s'inscrit dans le
cadre de visite fréquente entre les deux
pays il y a beaucoup de choses à
discuter en particulier la question de
la normalisation avec Israël qui est
quelque chose que les États-Unis
voudraient l'Arabie Saoudite faire
l'Arabie Saoudite résiste un peu ça va
certainement discuter cette semaine
Thomas Juno c'était très éclairant merci
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
c'est moi qui vous remercie pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]